henri ménudier bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france on le disait
nette victoire des conservateurs donc
dans gala merkel face à la droite
radicale
et pourtant certains sondages
annonçaient la rd vainqueur cette
victoire de la cedeao est ce que c'est
une surprise ou pas oui c'est une
surprise à mesure ou d'un cd vous a
perdu pratiquement dans toutes les
élections au cours des dernières années
et les derniers sondages ne s'était pas
extrêmement favorable on s'attendait à
ce qu'elle sait d où sortent en tête
mais pas avec eux un écart aussi aussi
important alors comment expliquer ce
succès c'est dû certainement au fait que
le gouvernement régional s'est
relativement bien comporté dans cette
crise données et des données des
solutions et surtout la fin de la
campagne électorale a été dominée par le
duel entre les chrétiens-démocrates et
l'extrême droite
la presse a beaucoup indiqué que le
risque d'une victoire de la droite
étaient été donnée donc je crois que
cela a contribué au dernier moment à
mobiliser les électeurs
disons le conservateur et ses lakers se
reporter sur l'épidémie on parle d'un
scrutin test pour les conservateurs
avant les prochaines élections
nationales de septembre ce résultat est
ce qu'il est rassurant pour la céder ou
oui il est rassurant mais on ne peut pas
aussi en tirer trop de trop
d'enseignements dans la mesure où sur un
résultat dans un angle c'était dans une
région qu'elle toujours été dominé par
les chrétiens-démocrates et il n'y a eu
que seuls ceux ci un démocrate qui a vu
gouverner cependant eu de 10 lecture si
dense est toujours été des chrétiens
démocrates avec des majorités en général
donc conservatrice de conservatrice de
droite
il est évident que pour un scrutin au
niveau fédérale 1 et 4 seront distribués
de façon tout
fait différente et une est pas sûr du
tout que les chrétiens démocrates
puissent s'imposer de cette façon au
niveau fédéral et ils ont surtout à
lutter contre la présence à la fois de
l'extrême droite est également des verts
et est ce que là le score de l'afd il
était également prévisible et
précisément dans ce land et pourquoi on
s'attendait à un score plus élevé des
données de l'extrême droite
je vous ai dit c'est sans doute le fait
que là les médias ont beaucoup insisté
sur le risque d'un le risque d'une
victoire des verts cem droite ce qui
aurait été tellement événement
considérable pour l'allemagne donc cela
a contribué à dramatiser l'issue du vote
et c'est ce qui fait que finalement il
ya plus de voix en faveur des chrétiens
démocrates en faveur de l'extrême droite
mais il n'empêche que l'extrême droite
reste quand même très forte
au-dessus de 20% dans ce lent comme dans
l'ensemble de l'allemagne de l'est
on constate si vous voulez que et ce
vote l'a confirmé la tendance sur
laquelle les chaînes droite est beaucoup
plus fortement implantée à l'est qu'à
l'ouest et cela va peser bien sûr dans
l'issue des élections fédérales
à la fin du mois de septembre alors la
cdo avait subi deux cuisants revers à en
mars lors de deux élections régionales
le parti montré du doigt notamment pour
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire est
montré du doigt aussi pour ses scandales
de corruption est ce que ces affaires
est l'impact encore elle a cédé ou en
allemagne
oui bien sûr je continue à jouer la
continuelle a joué un rôle mais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé hier c'est ce qu'on a
pu le voir aux côtés élections régiona
que vous avez mentionné au mois de mars
j'ai eu des élections régionales dans
deux länder dans le bade wurtemberg et
en rhénanie-palatinat et à chaque fois
ce sont des chefs de gouvernement
sortant qui l'ont emporté
c'est une façon si vous voulez pour les
gens de se rassurer
ne pas aller vers des changements trop
trop profond il y a eu des changements
dans les rapports de voix
finalement si on regarde ce qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans ces deux länder et
bien les gouvernements en place sont
restés avec les mêmes coalition et c'est
vraisemblablement ce qui va se produire
ce qui va se produire en saxe anhalt
c'est à dire que les électeurs veulent
du changement mais avec une certaine
continuité est précisément parce que la
situation actuelle est quand même
inquiétante avec la présence du gros
navires us la crise sanitaire et bien
les électeurs et préfère jouer la carte
de la sécurité
c'est à dire maintenir en place des
équipes qui sont au pouvoir
et est ce que ça veut dire que ça
renforce aussi armin laschet tu le chef
de la cv ou qui aspirent à la succession
de la chancelière angela merkel il est
réputé impopulaire ce résultat d'hier ce
qui est ce qu'il va renforcer sa
position
oui je pense que c'est un bon c'est un
beau succès imaginez que s'il accédait
ou avait encore perdu ces élections
comme elle a permis depuis au cours des
dernières années régulièrement dans
toutes les élections régionales ce
serait une catastrophe
bon il est évident maintenant que ce
résultat bien que régionalement limitée
va donner un nouvel élan à la campagne
électorale des chrétiens et des
chrétiens-démocrates et qu'ils vont dire
oui vous avez vous pouvez nous faire
confiance
on continuera à gérer le pays de façon
rassurante pour vous alors le succès
aussi de l'afd a même s'il a été
invaincue elle porte sur le fait que la
question de la lutte contre la migration
et et portait un parce ce par ce parti
est ce que la cd ou va devoir changer de
cap sans paraît également de ceux de ce
sujet ce qu il le fait d'ailleurs pour
pour assurer un certain électorat
oui bien sûr la question est une
question qui joue un rôle important dans
la dans le départ d'un débat électoral
mais actuellement une inquiétude n'est
pas trop grande à ce propos parce qu'on
constate que depuis l'année dernière
les le nombre de deux le nombre
d'immigrants venus en allemagne
forcément de fortement pc donc depuis
plusieurs années l'allemagne accueille
un nombre assez important de 10 me de
réfugiés et peut donc continuer à ce
rythme là qui n'est pas extrêmement
inquiétant bon en allemagne de l'est
façon générale il y a moins d'immigrants
que dans un lac en allemagne de l'ouest
donc c'est un sujet si vous voulez qui
va jouer un rôle
surtout si jamais il y avait une forte
poussée au cours de l'été venant de la
méditerranée et le père par exemple ou
du moyen-orient
mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas
vraiment le thème le thème essentiel se
passe explique aussi en partie une recul
de l'extrême droite qui est plutôt
tendance à mettre l'accent sur ce genre
de sujet alors les élections de
septembre prochain marqueront également
la fin de l'ère merkel
c'est une fin difficile ou pas pour la
chancelière ou au contraire une une
popularité intacte elle reste
extrêmement le populaire dont sa gestion
de la crise sanitaire est très discutée
discuter très contesté mais finalement
les électeurs ont l'habitude de la voir
au pouvoir elle et aidera penser que ces
décisions sont mûrement réfléchies ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui font ce paisible
et elle réfléchit beaucoup et ensuite
elle elle décide alors les élections
générales auront lieu le 26 septembre
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle va
quitter le pouvoir immédiatement le
mandat de l'actuel parlement le
bundestag elle se termine vers la
mi-novembre dont l aide resterait au
moins jusqu'à la mi novembre et elle
restera aussi aussi longtemps que son
successeur soit un homme ou une femme
sera élu donc ça peut aller jusque dans
le mois de juin au mois de
au moment du des chambres du congrès mme
merkel on la verra encore pendant
plusieurs mois
merci beaucoup henry ménudier pour votre
éclairage je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur émérite et spécialiste de
l'allemagne